i am ryan quinn this is what not to do
when starting a project
don't create an open-ended project make
sure the project has a point b
it needs to have a goal that helps with
a project focus and helps with design
decisions
and the project doesn't have to be
anything serious like i may start a
project with the express intent of
learning something or working for a
problem
uh once i reached that goal the project
is over uh accomplished what i set out
to accomplish
and it doesn't matter what shape the
project is in
it may be less than half baked at that
point but i
got out of it one to what i want to get
out of it
don't expect everything to be perfect
immediately
the project is going to be a mess and
that's okay running code can be fixed
but code that was never written cannot
be fixed
you know we're all going to build a
garbage pile at some point
you know i've built some garbage piles
and i've been pretty proud of some of
them
you know some other people have even
liked the garbage piles i've built
you know we're just doing the best that
we can and we just have to accept that
don't expect to jump to point b
immediately
it's going to be a journey and it's
probably going to look like the squiggly
line
you know after 20 years the journey
might look like the first or second
lines but
starting out it's definitely going to be
the third
you know the best example is building a
sandwich we know how to build a sandwich
because we built a lot of sandwiches but
telling someone who has never built a
sandwich how to build a sandwich
is amazingly hard they don't have the
knowledge
and they can't fill in the blanks
themselves yeah at the beginning of a
project
they're going to be a lot of blanks and
this can be intimidating
to get around this break everything down
to small steps
you know set small goals which are
reasonable to accomplish
and keep track of these goals for
instance
most of my projects start as hello world
programs
that that's when my steps get a working
program after that
it's make it do things you know fill
fill it out
make it useful if this sounds like
project
planning and project management that's
because it is that's where
that's where this comes from it's also
perfectly reasonable to attach rewards
to goals
so you know get some ice cream get a
cookie you know just something
something you like don't try to learn
more than one thing at a time
this this doesn't work very well when
i've crashed and burned it's
been because i've tried to learn two
more things at the same time
you know trying to learn concurrently
slows things down and limit ourselves to
one thing
lets us lean on our existing knowledge
base and focus
don't assume the project will get done
you know schedule time for
it take advantage of computer
hibernation and leave everything set up
just just so you can sit down and start
working
don't spend endless time analyzing
insignificant details
or bike shedding bike shedding is the
futile
investment of time and energy in
discussion of marginal technical issues
the origin example is arguing about the
color of the bike shed before it's been
built
i mean you got built up before you paint
it right you know get the project
working then fix the problems and add
features
it's easy to get lost searching for the
best whatever or doing what ifs
but you know try something and see if it
works if it doesn't
you know change course
they're going to be several iterations
of projects so work incrementally
with more time we get better at triaging
things and picking out what's important
don't feel bad about starting over
sometimes we pan ourselves into corner
and we need to reset everything
or sometimes we need to work on
something a couple times before things
start clicking
you know this happens and there's no
need to be precious with something which
isn't working
and we're gonna fail we're gonna be
stumped by something
uh spent like a week working on a django
or m problem
you know you know that's just how things
happen most of my job is figuring out
all the things that
all the ways things won't work before
finding the one thing that does
so we're going to have lots of failures
and restarts that's how we learn
uh so in summary we gain new knowledge
as we go
life is an iterative process and will we
bear tomorrow doing we're today